chico hay una pregunta que me atravesó y
que me acompañó durante muchísimos años
en que soy bueno siempre juntado alguna
vez en qué son buenos se han preguntado
alguna vez cuál es mi don
parque bien este mundo cuál es la misión
me gusta porque viene mayor y las caras
que hacen si obvio
vengo de una familia numerosa y muchos
hermanos levante la mano quién tiene más
de 4 hermanos
ay no que llevan tío a Hobbit
página hermano que no soltó ahí no lo
tenía hermana que tiene más de 5
hermanos
Mari 6
papá bueno vale voy tiene 13 tengo 7
hermanos
soy el quinto de esta familia numerosa
de antes de antes digo porque veo muchas
caras jóvenes descuento a los que tienen
un poquito más de 30 antes había
solamente un televisor con 3 canales
a color y el quinto de los varones de
estos que duermen en la pieza con
cuchilla y que si llegabas tarde alguien
te ocupa en la cama y dibujaba dibujo de
chico nadie en casa dibujando dibujo ni
hermanos no dibuja papá mamá no tengo
idea empecé a dibujar de chiquito y
tengo la particularidad de que puedo
dibujar una caricatura de una persona en
menos de 30 segundos
[Aplausos]
esto me llevo aquí en la época de
secundario yo hacía caricaturas está
todo tipo dibujando y la profe de
historia decía Buteler deje de hacer
caricatura y yo seguí dibujando y
Buteler de que hacer caricatura y llegue
a sexto año no sé cómo hackear quinto
año sexto año y vieron que uno cuando
tiene 17 años sabe lo que quiere hacer
en su vida
bien bien y yo no sabía que así
solamente dibuja a ver entonces digo que
tuviera algo que está en Octubre
Noviembre del sexto año todos ya saben
que estudiar todos van a ser médicos
abogados contadores y yo me metí en que
me metí y por supuesto en arquitectura
pero no estabas en el cursillo digo esto
no es para mí y me metí en diseño
industrial y cuando me di cuenta estaba
en Tercera ni la carrera o cuarto ni la
carrera y yo seguiré preguntando bien
que soy bueno os parece que vine o cuál
es mi don o lo que fuera pero ni se han
ido un profesor me dice pues tendrías
que hacer caricaturas en fiestas no
tenía que ser dibujante beso dibujante
que hoy no viene fiesta ya igual entro
mío me dijo es que voy a trabajar yo de
esto si yo no soy bueno en esto le ha
pasado alguna vez
quizá buses IP interna suele ser la que
los boicotea
le ha pasado a ver si tú tienes que
decir algo o este entusiasmo que el
profesor este me transmitió el hijo
decir vamos con eso mi cabeza dijo pero
te aseguro pero fíjate que la carrera en
esa época el descuento se acuerde que le
dije la época de antes había teléfono
fijo en casa conocen los teléfonos fijos
para los más chicos el teléfono fijo
tenía un candado de la siesta
había que se rió con ganas que
suene el teléfono yo vivía con papá y
mamá medicine mamá te llaman a ti y me
dijeron que tú eras en fiesta y yo digo
mira lo que hago la casa estaba la mamá
el papá la chica que iba a cumplir 15
años
cobras
oye le madre me crítica está ahí la
llevo a la fiesta lo dibujamos dibujamos
no 123 dijo que 20 personas tome Ferrer
va a ir cuartito y me pagaron yo no
puedo creer yo dijiste lo mío el martes
suene el teléfono en casa de mi mamá y
dicen por el tema de las caricaturas si
Jaca el tipo ya había robado la cuestión
que siempre si dibujar dibujar dibujar
dibujar donde había gente Butteler
estaba dibujando fiesta de 15 casamiento
velorio todos los lugares de había mucha
gente yo dibujado dibujado dibujado la
historia cuenta que pase los últimos
años de la carrera universitaria
juntando la plata que hacía de de hacer
caricatura a los 5 años de mi primer
fiesta me compré mi primer casa con la
plata que junte dibujar
[Aplausos]
y se la parte linda ya se la parte del
guau dice que natural que le salió
segundo hueso bien
yo no podía agarrar un vaso era tal la
tendinitis que tenía
que el traumatólogo Nisa es porque me
dice RAM y a este ritmo está tendinitis
aguda si va a volver crónica si vos no
paras de abusar
Eldon o esto tan lindo que tenéis que ir
lo de dibujar en fiestas y en ese
momento yo me encontré con una gran
crisis que fue que hago con tantas
fiestas que tenía cerradas hasta fin de
año y el año que viene
a quién le delego veo que ahora saca que
la mayoría sabe delegar y lo hace muy
bien
me gustaría ser vistosas risitas
cómo voy a mandar un dibujante que si
mando un dibujante de fiesta él iba a
dar su tarjeta y si da su tarjeta lo van
a contratar allí no me van a llamar
nunca más a mí bien que de vuelta a la
cabeza de 1 género y esos miedos muchas
veces infundados
la historia termina con qué
tuve que mandar por obligación a dos o
tres dibujantes a las fiestas de este
fin de semana porque yo no podía dibujar
y descubrir algo increíble que fue que
pase de tener dos fiestas por fin de
semana tener 10 fiestas por fin de
semana a trabajar menos de la mitad del
tiempo que me dedicaba a mí a dibujar y
podía estar haciendo sociales y
charlando y visitando y haciendo crecer
la empresa en una manera inimaginable
y gran aprendizaje que tuve en la
pregunta que le hice el principio en que
eso es bueno
yo no lo tuve en ese momento pienso
tranquila porque en realidad no me salía
preguntando pensé que era eso pensé que
había venido a este mundo a dibujar y no
había había mucho más había un vacío
todavía interno sea que les contaba que
eres quinto y 7 hermanos que había un
solo televisor y que te lo hizo tenía
tres canales y en orden de prioridad
está guapa después mamá y después sin
cuernos arriba entonces de chico empecé
a leer siempre leí mucho tengo la
particularidad de leer más de 50 60
libros por año desde que tengo nueve o
10 anime encanta leer por lo general la
gente que leer automáticamente y pasamos
a escribir en el año 2012 se me ocurre
escribir un libro
hermano de quién ha escrito un libro
alguna vez
más dos escribir un libro tiene un 10%
de inspiración voy a escribir un libro y
un 90% que se llama transpiration que
hay que sentarse escribir
está muy sé domingo en casa de mis
viejos y mi mamá me dice que iba a
escribir más y nunca escribiste
le ha pasado alguna vez que algún
familiar y los quiere mucho cuando esté
en cuenta que van a hacer algo nuevo
algo distinto algo disruptivo porque vas
a hacer algo porque no mejor quédate
dónde estás haciendo lo que hay que
hacer
te ha pasado que a ver si Messi pero ya
ya tenéis que tener familia tenéis esto
te ibas a meter en algo nuevo han
sentido alguna vez y se llama interna de
hacer algo decirte tengo ganas de
empezar con este emprendimiento tengo
ganas de este proyecto de este viaje y
cuando lo contaste alguien que te quiere
no porque no hablemos la gente que no la
quiere que hay un montón de gente que no
los quiere a usted también
producto dicto de cuidarnos de quedarnos
donde estamos así porque escuché que hay
dos verdades absolutas que nos vamos a
morir está bien
y que lo único constante es el cambio
empecé a escribir estuve más de 9 meses
escribiendo levantándome temprano la
mañana acostándome tarde la noche
sacándole tiempo la familia al deporte
al trabajo y en noviembre del 2013
presento mi primer novela 400 días
relaciones en tiempos modernos una
novela sobre las infidelidades
levante la mano quién es infiel acá
Aina que grito viste
giotrif oasis
ya k pasó algo increíble
que a mí me explotó el alma en mil
pedazos no fue haber escrito la novela
no fue a verla presentado
las devoluciones de los lectores
fue cuando empecé a recibir mails y
mensaje de gente que hacía Rami pusiste
en palabras
lo que yo vivo con mi vecina
o no
en realidad fue increíble empezar a ver
qué
había escrito historia sabéis Cristo
emociones había escrito sentimientos de
gente que necesitaba exteriorizar lo
increíble
al día de hoy acabo de presentar miau
libro y sigo recibiendo
esos aprendizajes y sea recomendaciones
Isa gratificaciones de lector de la
persona que hace suya aquello que con
tanto sacrificio en algún momento yo
escribí en un horno ordenador o en una
computadora
que iba a escribir vos y nunca
escribiste
cuántas veces has tenido ganas de hacer
algo a empezar y sin miedo infundado y
ese qué dirán y ese mejor lo dejo para
el año que viene mejor me espero
así cinco años Juan
me dice Rami
tengo un cáncer
y yo que estoy acostumbrado a ayudar y
acompañar a la gente digo Juan que
podemos hacer porque vos tenés un
problema
las demás cosas son situaciones a
resolver
todo lo que estamos acá mayoría queremos
tenemos problemas la mayoría de las
cosas que creen que son problemas son
situaciones ojo hay gente que si tiene
problemas Juan tenía un problema yo no
te puedo ayudar le digo lo que voy a
hacer polvo y empezar a correr nunca he
corrido
juego al fútbol en bici nunca había
empezado a correr
cuento en casa voy a correr una maratón
León termal Kia corrido la maratón la
maratón tiene
un 10 % de ganas de cogerla y tiene un
90% de transpiración de entrenamiento de
fuerza Diana
alguien me tiro mucho dice que va a
correr no si nunca corriste
el kilómetro 40 de mi primer maratón
muchísima gente y se queda antes de la
línea I'm historia que dice que tiene
que ver con lo que pensamos
con lo que nos frena con creer que ya
estamos
ininterrumpidamente decirse año fui
corriendo por Juan
hace 20 días Juan se fue
y yo en dos semanas cruzó los Andes
corriendo por el no estarás dice que iba
a estar de una manera mucho más real que
vas a correr o si nunca corriste y está
triste historia que les comparto nada
tienen que ver conmigo
porque mientras usted me están mirando
sé que están pensando en sus historias
en sus dones en sus ganas
y en aquello que han dejado de hacer y
que el momento ahora
Isayama interior eso de que capaz que no
tiene que ver con el trabajo capaz que
no tiene que ver con la familia para que
tiene que ver con un viaje que aparque
tiene que ver con hacer una llamada una
persona que hace un montón que no le
llamas y que sabes que lo tienes que
hacer
empecé diciéndole que me protegen que
son bueno se preguntaron alguna vez
sabes la respuesta por lo general hago
esta pregunta que me sé si soy bueno en
esto vamos a hacer esto pero hay mucha
gente que todavía no lo sabe
y que esté en búsqueda
esta semana pensaba y encontré esta
frase y si las traje
que me pareció increíble
le escribió Steve thomlinson saben quién
es Steve Thompson
yo tampoco tengo ya pero le encontré y
me encantó vestir si estás acá
me muere cita no
si tienes dos o tres pasiones no crees
que tienes que escoger alguna no las
eches quédate con todo lo que te
apasiona
y para cerrar
anoche
mientras pensaba el cierre de esta
charla Ted ex me pregunta en qué soy
bueno y lo descubrí
quién que se lo cuente
mejor lo dejo para la próxima charla Ted
gracias
[Aplausos]